de manière à ce que le cours débute par
une démonstration le portage s'avère
plus compliqué que prévu un mélange de
nouage et de tissage avec au centre de
la technique le confort de l'enfant on
le lisse dans le dos de l'enfant en
remontant le tissu jusqu'au dessus de sa
tête de manière à ce qu'on puisse créer
un soutien autour de l'année du bébé une
fois la technique mémorisée les mamans
doivent passer à la pratique et les
premiers essais ne sont pas les plus
convaincants ouais je pense qu'au début
il faut il faut avoir des professionnels
pour nous aider puis après je pense que
c'est nickel
non c'est cool sur le ventre le dos ou
la hanche une dizaine de nouages
différents permet de porter son enfant
en toute sécurité une technique
ancestrale sur d'autres continents en
passent de se développer en Occident
naturellement les trois quarts de la
planète prend un bout de tissu les
femmes de la planète prennent un bout de
tissu selon room d'une manière ou d'une
autre assez savante autour de leur corps
et mettre leur bébé dedans les bénéfices
du portage sont surtout importants pour
l'enfant il lui permet de découvrir le
monde tout en étant rassuré par le
contact de l'adulte les mamans ont
également y trouve leur compte c'est
idéal pour avoir les mains libres pour
pouvoir quelque chose à la maison bon
quand ils sont tout petits comme ça on
n'ose pas forcément les mettre sur le
dos mais dans quelques mois quand elle
va pouvoir aller dans mon dos là je vais
pouvoir faire plein de choses à la
maison avec les mains libres et ça c'est
très très pratique
de plus en plus de professionnels et de
médecins militent aujourd'hui pour le
développement de cette technique de
locomotion le portage en écharpe permet
à l'enfant de garder une position
naturelle
le bébé doit être porté arrondi puisque
la colonne vertébrale n'est pas musclée
à la naissance elle mettra un an à se
muscler complètement pendant tout ce
temps l'enfant doit avoir la possibilité
de se mettre en boule de se mettre en
petite grenouille le portage pourrait
donc devenir un moyen de plus en plus
utilisé en France il se développe déjà
Marie-Laure donné un cours par mois il y
a deux ans cette année elle doit revêtir
son rôle de professeur quatre fois